Britain jails more people than any other
country in western Europe our prisons
are at Breaking Point nearly 83 000
inmates and Rising if we haven't got the
adequate system to put in place to house
those criminals then I'm afraid we're
going to have a lot more uh challenges
Downstream and it's going to seriously
impact Upon Our communities prisons are
made for a purpose
um for an individual to go out and serve
their serve their time for the crime
they've committed but also to be
mentored and rehabilitated back into
society with the current situation I
don't think that's going to happen in
the Commons the prisons Minister
announced a short-term fix I'm
announcing today that we've written to
the National Police Chief's Council to
request the temporary use of up to 400
police cells through an established
protocol known as operation safeguard
this will provide the immediate
additional capacity we need in the
coming weeks to ensure the smooth
running of the prison State and to
continue taking dangerous criminals off
the streets
tougher sentencing laws are part of the
reason the government also blamed a
recent Barrister's strike over legal aid
payments the strike delayed trials and
left defendant in prison custody for
longer
the lawyers said it wasn't their fault
the criminal Bar Association and our
action that tried to shine a light on
what was going on because of the years
in fact Decades of underfunding in our
Criminal Justice System had meant that
we just didn't have enough barristers we
need to invest in people and have those
people back as well as judges actually
in the crown courts to deal with all
these cases and a huge backlog which is
now over 62 000.
says the use of police sales will be
temporary last time it lasted months but
how suitable are they
police cells are very austere they don't
have beds like prison cells they don't
have TVs they're very hit and miss on
showers and toilet facilities but of
course there's no cooking facilities for
police cells they use microwave meals so
that adds to the pressure that we're all
feeling
police chief said they would ensure the
temporary system was as safe and
efficient as possible but lower rank
officers warned that the plan was
ill-conceived and would put them and the
public in danger
Martin brunt Sky News